today i want to talk about the most
important things you need to know if you
have acid reflux so i have this diagram
of the stomach there's a valve on the
top part and there's a valve on the
lower part
the valve on the top prevents
acid and food from regurgitating up
through the esophagus the valve in the
bottom controls the food from the
stomach into the small intestine as well
as controlling the food and bile
from regurgitating back up into the
stomach so both of these valves
are sphincters
it's like a circular muscle that is
controlled by the autonomic nervous
system so the muscular control is kind
of a gradual contraction
and a gradual relaxation until it's
fully open and so the problem we have
with these valves is they're if they're
open at the wrong time or close at the
wrong time we can have a big problem
with acid and bile ending up in the
wrong place now because they're
controlled by the autonomic nervous
system
that means that they're highly
influenced with this thing called stress
and this is why there are so many
digestive problems that can be affected
by
stress like acid reflux heartburn and
the list goes on and on and on and so if
you have acid reflux and a lot of stress
you know you're gonna have to do
something to reduce that stress before
it starts improving now the other thing
that controls these sphincters is
calcium calcium has the function of
muscular contraction
so it helps close these sphincters but
most of the time people are lacking the
vitamin that controls calcium i'm
talking about vitamin d if you're
deficient in vitamin d
you're not going to have enough calcium
and the valve is not going to close
fully and incidentally vitamin d
also acts like cortisol in the body and
there's a lot to do with controlling
stress
and by taking vitamin d
that can actually help reduce your
stress and can help directly close the
valve just from the function of vitamin
d itself now the other cause of this
valve on the top of the stomach opening
at the wrong time
is because you don't have enough
hydrochloric acid in your stomach
apparently there are receptors or
sensors in that valve for hydrochloric
acid so we have the synchronization of
food coming through the valve closing
and acid increasing so you can get a
complete digestion so if you don't have
enough hydrochloric acid or the acid in
your stomach is not acid enough
that valve might not close and that can
cause the regurgitation effect so what
can cause
a deficiency of hydrochloric acid well
one is low chlorides as in low
salt so if you're on a low salt diet or
not taking enough sea salt that could be
the reason why you don't have enough
hydrochloric acid also it takes
potassium to also make hydrochloric acid
so you need those electrolytes
as the building blocks to make
hydrochloric acid now another big cause
of low hydrochloric acid is medication
induced
hypochlorhydria
that is low stomach acid
caused by antacids
especially the ppis now there are also
foods that actually can aggravate the
situation gluten
grains
sugar
of course alcohol
and omega-6 fatty acids as in all the
soy oil the canola oil the corn oil
the cottonseed oil and of course all the
processed foods and the junk foods those
can not only disrupt the opening closing
of the valves but they can also disrupt
the production of hydrochloric acid let
me first talk about the importance of
hydrochloric acid okay number one its
role in intestinal hormones you have all
sorts of hormones that are involved in
your digestion and your small intestine
that's secreted from the pancreas that's
secreted from the small intestine itself
and without hydrochloric acid
they can't work a lot of the enzymes
that are in the upper part of the
digestive system they're activated by a
certain ph hydrochloric acid being an
acid activates these enzymes so they can
work all right number two hcl prepares
folate
and b12
for absorption number three hydrochloric
acid helps the absorption of minerals
i'm talking about calcium magnesium
potassium
zinc
and iron all right number four
hydrochloric acid is also necessary for
something called the intrinsic factor
for the absorption of b12 another
mechanism of b12 absorption if you don't
have enough b12 you're going to have a
lot of neurological problems and a lot
of pain from nerve damage all right next
one is hcl
is vital in the prevention of small
intestinal bacterial
overgrowth this is the prevention of
bacteria growing in the small intestine
that's the wrong place we want bacteria
growing in the large colon not the small
intestine and so without hydrochloric
acid you can get sibo hcl is vital in
preventing pathogens microbes that are
unfriendly going through the stomach and
invading the body so we need this
hydrochloric acid
to kill off
unfriendly bacteria
fungus
viruses that are in our foods and also
hcl is vital in preventing food
allergies because we want to take this
protein break it down fully into amino
acids and so if it's not fully broken
down your immune system can react to it
and you can develop allergies all right
so let me just touch briefly on the
valve on the bottom part of the stomach
okay
and this valve is very important in
preventing bile from regurgitating up
into the stomach and then up into the
esophagus
bile can
irritate the esophagus just as much as
hydrochloric acid because it's a
detergent and it can break down the
mucous layer and create a lot of pain
and irritation now there's three main
culprits or problems with that happening
number one excess belly fat if you have
too much visceral fat
all that fat can put pressure up into
this area and cause a regurgitation of
bile back up into the stomach
number two hiatal hernia and for more
information about that i put a video
down below so you can learn a real
simple technique
to help that condition and lastly if you
have a gallbladder problem or you have
bile sludge or even gallstones that's
obstructing the flow of bile that can
create a backup bile into the system and
the solution for that is
purify bile salts all right so what are
the very important things you need to do
if you have acid reflux number one
i would recommend starting out taking
the tane hydrochloride
methane hydrochloride is a really good
remedy for acid reflux it's going to
increase the concentration of acid in
your stomach and the problem with a lot
of people when they take obtain
hydrochloride is they think that
one or two with a meal is going to solve
it
usually they're going to need a lot more
maybe five six seven eight with a meal
especially in the beginning and you
would want to take it right before the
meal and you'll see it'll create a huge
improvement in the digestion of your
food and a lessening of the backup of
acid that's coming into your esophagus
also apple cider vinegar is very very
important to add with that and you'll
find great relief if you add both of
those together now
if you're taking betaine heterochloride
and apple cider vinegar and you feel
worse it aggravates the problem that
could mean you either have an ulcer or
gastritis in which case you need to
switch your plan of action and start
taking chlorophyll or some organic raw
wheatgrass juice powder so that can help
heal
the irritation in your esophagus and
your stomach the best vegetable or even
food for acid reflux
is cabbage okay all forms of cabbage and
even sauerkraut so make mental note of
that all right number three very
important reduce your stress do whatever
you can to reduce your stress i have a
thousand videos on how to do that
all right number four intermittent
fasting if you're consuming
six small meals or eating frequently
just think about what's happening you're
stressing the entire digestive system
intermittent fasting the decrease of
frequency of eating especially if you
can do two meals or even one meal a day
that's called omad will greatly improve
your acid reflux why
because it gives your digestive system a
chance to reset and heal and not work so
hard all right number five vitamin d
i've already mentioned that very
important to prevent acid reflux
number six zinc
l-carnosine is not only good for
ulcers
gastritis it's also good for gerd and
acid reflux in fact zinc l-carnosine is
good for anything
that's inflamed in your entire
gastrointestinal tract
and number seven
taking a very good probiotic because if
you have the microbes helping you digest
in the lower part of your your system
that'll take a huge stress off the top
part of the digestive system because
they're all connected alright thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
video hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your
success story
please share it in the link down below